Lisa war eine Influencerin der
rechtsradikalen Szene in Deutschland.
Monatelang hetzte sie auf
Youtube gegen Muslime,
Migranten und Migrantinnen und
gegen die Regierung.
Die unkontrollierte Masseneinwanderung
spaltet unser Land seit 2015.
Heimat geht verloren!
Mit ihren Auftritten in den Sozialen Medien
erreichte sie hunderttausende Menschen.
Es geht nur um Angst schüren
und um die Personen so weit zu
manipulieren, dass die einem am Ende
alles glauben und dann auch
zu allem bereit sind.
Lisa ist mittlerweile aus der
rechten Szene ausgestiegen.
Ihren Nachnamen sollen wir nicht nennen.
Sie erhält Morddrohungen von
früheren Weggefährten.
Und doch spricht sie heute offen
darüber,
wie Rechte über die Sozialen Medien
junge Menschen auf ihre Seite ziehen.
Es beginnt meist ganz harmlos.
Rechtsradikale präsentieren auf Plattformen
wie Instagram eine vermeintlich heile Welt.
Glatze, Bomberjacke und Springerstiefel
sieht man auf rechten Kanälen kaum noch.
Stattdessen Bilder,
die Werte transportieren,
die häufig von Rechten
instrumentalisiert werden:
Tradition, Natur, Gemeinschaft.
Unpolitisch und unproblematisch wirkt das
Ganze nur auf den ersten Blick.
Die Sozialen Medien sind in der Hinsicht
Brandbeschleuniger in
Radikalisierungsprozessen, weil sie einfach
so unschuldig
und so unverfänglich rüberkommen.
Das ist, glaube ich, das größte Problem an
der Sache, das sind eben Ausdrucksweisen,
die nicht unbedingt auf ein rechtsextremes
Weltbild hindeuten.
Mit Instagram-Posts
und Youtube-Videos
können Rechte unkontrolliert
die Massen erreichen.
Mit geschickt gestalteten Inhalten schüren sie
Fremdenhass und Nationalismus.
Das Ziel: ein möglichst niedrigschwelliger
Einstieg in die rechtsextreme Gedankenwelt.
Der manipulative Umgang mit den Sozialen
Medien wird sogar in Schulungen vermittelt,
zum Beispiel organisiert von rechtsextremen
Gruppen wie der Identitären Bewegung
oder der Jugendorganisation
der rechtspopulistischen Partei
„Alternative für Deutschland“.
Lisa erzählt, dass sie bei
so einer Schulung dabei war.
Es ging darum, wie tritt man auf
im Internet als Person?
Wie kleidet man sich, wie wirkt man seriös?
Der Neue Rechte hat jetzt ’nen schönen
Haarschnitt, er trägt ’n Polohemd.
Er ist gebildet, er hat ’nen
guten Schulabschluss.
Er möchte Familie, er trinkt keinen Alkohol,
er geht nicht auf Rechtsrock-Konzerte.
Es ist ein kompletter Wandel, und den
bekommt man da sehr, sehr gut vermittelt.
Diese Form der subtilen politischen
Einflussnahme scheint zu greifen
und wird laut Experten noch verstärkt –
durch Algorithmen und
Filterblasen der Sozialen Medien.